why don't we talk about india's farmers
because uh uh this is a very the biggest
protest ever in
human you guys know the number how many
people protested a quarter of a billion
people pro
participated in a protest basically
every adult in the united states
basically every no no every adult in the
united states is 150
every working adult in the united states
is 150 a quarter of a billion
people protested in india this is
ridiculous
why india's farmers are protesting for
nearly two weeks ten thousand
tens of thousands of india farmers have
camped out on new delhi to protest a set
of new
farm bill passed by countries parliament
countries parliament and september
thousands more
from the neighboring states of harayana
punjab and uttar pradesh
look to set to join in coming days even
as police try to block them
from entering the city these protests
are not isolated movement on november
26th an estimated 250 million citizens
participate in 24-hour general strike
held to challenge the new laws 24 hour
on november 26th
this the magnitude of the protest should
not be a surprise
agriculture employs about half of indian
workforce although it accounts for only
one-sixth of india's gdp some of india's
farmers are among the country's poorest
people
but government policies have long
protected them from the ravages of open
market prices
they cannot enter contracts with private
companies a practice known in india's
contract farming
and sell those but some of them are
hoarding anyways there's a lot of stuff
going on there obviously india's
millions of farmers are clearly angle
angry they believe the new rules
will open them to exploitation by giant
companies and as barakta dude writes in
washington post
there's broad national sympathy for the
protest the moral force of the indian
farmer cannot be underestimated she
argues describing scenes of the elderly
protest
spreading blankets under the wheels of
their trucks to sleep in the cold winter
there is subliminal collective guilt at
the sight of farmers
thoughts man my heart goes out to them i
mean these people are making on average
a month and you're thinking to yourself
here in america well you know these are
indian farmers how does this affect us
well if you uh peel it back a little bit
um that's 68 of the world spices that
they produce in india it's 40
of the cotton produced in the world
basmati rice
comes from india they're the largest
milk producer in the world
and they're the second biggest producer
in fruits and vegetables so it's
unbelievable now
weren't we supposed to like that what
you're saying that's very powerful the
world is affected by
the world should be paying attention to
this yeah i mean this affects clothing
you know in so many different things
and we were all led to believe that this
new prime minister of india was supposed
to be this progressive guy
you know he's the one behind it yep he's
the one behind it
but now he's trying to sell it like this
is going to be more opportunity but what
these individual farmers are worried
about is
you know the big big factory farms are
going to come over and take over
everything and you know what here's the
other thing too and if you really want
to get
conspiratory here if could you weave
china into this
i mean china is it a possibility that
they have something to do with this too
to get this protest going during kovid
to maybe lead to more deaths in india i
mean during these protests people are
going to be close together i don't know
but this is a big problem and i hope
they get it solved
250 million people
protesting 24 hours how long did they
protest 24 hours
uh november 26th how many stores were
looted
god knows right i don't know hopefully
they
but look i don't know much about the
indian farming uh
economy whatsoever so this is where i'm
gonna
pass the ball back to tom he did his
research but
250 million people that is absurd i mean
there's how many billion i mean one
point something billion people
that live in india mm-hmm are they gonna
are they they're more than china or
they're
passing china they're not yet but
they're gonna pass china i don't know
who's that making babies what's the
popular what's the population india
versus china china's got a 300 we're
just looking population in general
china's got a 300 million lead i believe
india is 1.35 billion oh they're about
to pass up china they're about to pass
china by when
i mean at this pace it's not far off
yeah but go ahead make your point no
there's no point here it's just
there's a shitload of people in india
and clearly this is affecting
india this is affecting the world 250
that's like if
every single person an adult in america
protested in one day
300 in the last 20 years farmers have
been affected by
the regulations for a long time this
isn't a new thing this has been going on
for decades it's nothing new
but in the last kind maybe this is not
not a bad video for us to make similar
to us china trade war to to make this
video i think it's actually a very good
idea to make the video i think it would
get a lot of in the last year
yeah i know i we have i've been to india
you know we had a great time with india
our audience
you know we we love the indian folks and
they're
very hard-working people and i kind of
like that capitalism has helped them out
a lot they're coming up aggressively
they went from being a
non-issue gdp wise i think they're in
the top seven right now
and climbing aggressively and i think
they they can still they can compete for
the top three spot
in no time uh gdp gdp no question
between u.s brotherhood let me put it to
you this way some of the best
engineers in america are indian
iit iit produce of course we do they're
geniuses
iit produces some of the best engineers
in the world there's a study that was
done
where they went to do a market research
they went on the mit campus
and then they went on the iit campus to
see who produces better engineers and
they gave them some basic tests
here's a wire here's a battery here's
this make this light turn on the mit
people they don't know how to do it the
iit's like what do you mean this is
elementary this is nothing to us
and this kind of term so iit produces
ridiculous engineers so
india's going to be competing in the
last 20 years do you know how many
farmers people who own farms do you know
how many of them have committed suicide
in the last 20 years in america or india
in india
how many have committed suicide
specifically in the farming industry
what do you think the number's on the
last 20 200 000. 300 000 of them have
committed suicide
the last 20 years when they're only
making 140 a month how are you going to
take care of your family
this is a v and by the way you know
farmers it's not like a sexy thing you
do you know you're like what do you i'm
a farmer oh my gosh she's a farmer you
know
nobody sits there and says when somebody
says i'm in the military what do you say
ah you know
thank you for your service bro it's all
good right when a war happens you kind
of
like these soldiers to go to war when
you're getting arrested somebody's
breaking into your house you kind of
like cops
when all of a sudden the cost for what
you're buying skyrockets
you're looking around getting pissed off
at people you realize what happened over
here well
regulation farmers you're hurting them
yeah the big corp remember when we did
that one conversation with chad solomon
the owner of that
the rancher the the he was talking about
meat and what's going on with meat
prices in america where a handful of
companies are really controlling
everything and it's forcing meat prices
to go
up and you now don't know whether your
meat is from america or not because they
don't want to put it on there so it
doesn't say made in usa
you don't know if your meat your buying
is from china or not go ahead
even when it's made from made in says
made in the usa could just be packed in
the u.s
it's packed in u.s but it's made
somewhere else so they're pushing for
the farmers in u.s want to push to say
that this meat is made in usa
the big companies are saying no we don't
care if it is or not we just will say
we'll pack it in usa
but we sell it at a price and then i
asked the question i said how many
people actually care about the fact that
you know where your meat is uh produce
and people say it matters to me when's
the last time you checked
and everybody's like i never checked
that's the point so then you start
looking at ranchers and saying huh
these ranchers are more important i
never thought about ranch i didn't what
does a rancher's day look like
what do they do listen ranchers farmers
these people what they do is very very
important and it's very sad what's going
on to india uh i hope
uh uh i would encourage them to not stop
voicing
their opinions and where they're at and
hopefully eventually
someone's gonna turn i know it got ugly
a little bit you know you know you had
the government got in you're talking
about guns and you know it got very ugly
if you've seen some of the riots
that's not looking good well and the
other other right there you think of
them as maybe a little bit more reserved
or docile
as far as their character and whatnot
but the passion you see in these photos
with these protesters man this is
everything to them you could just tell
you know they're not going to go away
this is going to be a battle for that
government to try to win well something
that
that resonated with me when you were i
make a note of it for video i think
that's definitely a video
given uh your impassioned point right
there was we've learned the term
i went on the terms that we talked about
when it came to work you know obviously
a hybrid work model virtual
decentralized but one of the terms that
we've
come to learn is essential worker yeah
farmer is an essential worker it's not
the sexiest job
unless you're going i think there's a
website called farmers only i don't know
how i know about that but
farmers only yeah but uh check out only
fans of farms only but these are
essential workers that is good
okay that is good hey by the way you
know about farmers
yes of course you know of course of
course i know parmesan
wouldn't it behoove us as a country to
become aligned with india as much as we
can as big as they be coming with you i
think so
i think so too because they're a
democracy they're the largest
share common enemy and they have a
stronger backbone towards china than us
how many apps have they banned from
china
150 apps or something like that i kind
of like it if we're gonna if we're gonna
go against china
you know uh yeah no i i could have india
on our side
you